bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir un journaliste de talent
qui vient de remporter le Prix étudiant
du Livre politique dont SCP est
partenaire bonsoir dynamic ciao et merci
d'être là bravo pour dossier V13 chez
plomb vous êtes reporters à quotidien
sur TMC pour qui vous avez suivi les 9
mois de ce procès hors norme des
attentats du 13 novembre et ça donne
vous allez le voir un très beau livre
illustré par le dessinateur judiciaire
Valentin Pasquier qui partage ce prix
avec vous on va y revenir longuement
tout à l'heure mais on commence avec un
chiffre alarmant plus 32% en un an le
nombre des violences contre les élus
explosent et le 49.3 n'arrange rien
menace de mort anonyme permanence
saccagé les députés subissent une
nouvelle vague de violence après la
crise des gilets jaunes et la crise
sanitaire alors de quoi notre démocratie
est-elle malade et quelle sursaut
possibilité grand débat avec nos invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau et puis
20h15 les parties pris de nous
affranchis et Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée vous me
suivez
[Musique]
on s'habitue on s'habitue à leur compte
devrait jamais s'y habituer aux
permanence de députés saccagé aux
intimidations menaces de mort alors que
se passe-t-il dans le pays pour qu'à
chaque crise les élus soient pris pour
cible les plaintes sont déposées les
poursuites judiciaires engagées mais
l'on sont tous que depuis le 49-3 la
situation devient très inquiétante
bonsoir Frédéric ganski bonsoir et merci
d'être là vous êtes député MoDem de
Gironde votre permanence parlementaire
de Pessac a été tagué trois fois vous
nous direz précisément ce qui s'est
passé bonsoir Jean garrigue bonsoir ravi
de vous retrouver sur ce plateau vous
êtes historien spécialiste d'histoire
parlementaire et politique vous nous
direz si cette violence contre les élus
et véritablement nouvelle ou pas bonsoir
Laetitia avia une habituée de cette
émission on est ravi de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui vous êtes ancienne député la
République en marche et vous avez aussi
subi des insultes à la fois racistes des
menaces de mort vous êtes l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi qui porte votre nom
sur la haine en ligne les réseaux
sociaux on va en parler énorme terrain
xxl de la violence contre les élus
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire enfin bonsoir
Jean-Baptiste Julia merci d'être là vous
êtes philosophe professeur agrégé de
philo doctorants et vous enseigner à la
Sorbonne azzinamation évidemment votre
regard de reporter de terrain nous
intéresse la violence vous la constatez
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez dans le
pays et bien n'hésitez pas à intervenir
quand vous le souhaitez on commence avec
les chiffres Stéphane blackowski bien
sûr recrudescence de quelle violence
contre les élus précisément le chrono de
Blacko pour démarrer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir
Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
que se passe-t-il dans le pays alors
vous avez réclamé des chiffres vous
allez avoir des chiffres regardez sur ce
grand écran des chiffres assez
inquiétants puisqu'on voit que les
agressions l'an dernier contre les élus
ont augmenté de 32%, c'est-à-dire que ça
remonte par les préfectures plus de 2000
agressions donc essentiellement des
insultes des menaces des dégradations
sans voir trop relativiser faut quand
même noter que les violences physiques
elles ça représente moins d'1% de
l'ensemble de ces agressions et c'est
pas et c'est plutôt stable donc ça ce
sont les chiffres de l'an dernier mais
depuis le début de l'année notamment
avec le débat sur les retraites on a
sentiment qu'il y a peut-être pas un
regain mais en tout cas que ça ne s'est
pas calmer vous voyez on a fait des
sélections on a Frédéric zinski qui est
avec nous qui est élu modem ça
permanence a été taguée trois fois près
de Bordeaux dégradé même vandaliser là
on est à Lille chez violette spielboot
Renaissance on a mûri son domicile ça
c'est le pavé dans la vitrine direction
a publié enfin
le public plutôt une lettre dans
laquelle on menaçait de s'en prendre à
son bébé de 4 mois donc oui la situation
est inquiétante et c'est bien organisé
un débat donc d'habitude dans ce genre
de débat j'essaie de rester neutre de
pas donner mon avis mais là je vous le
dis quitte à choqué la violence je suis
contre voilà c'est pas bien je vous le
dis ça va peut-être voir encore une fois
mais bon c'est bon c'est mon métier de
chroniqueur donc en fait vous comprenez
bien que je suis pas le seul personne
n'est pour la violence mais il y a un
problème dans ce pays c'est qu'on est
arrivé à un moment on a l'impression que
la violence c'est devenu le seul moyen
de se faire entendre donc en disant ça
je repense un slogan que j'ai vu tout
comme tout le monde a vu pendant les
gilets jaunes pas de casseurs pas de 20h
alors ça c'est bien trouvé parce que
effectivement c'est une provocation mais
en même temps c'est difficile de dire le
contraire bon on a bien compris que
toutes les chaînes de télé ou presque
couraient après l'audience et la
violence évidemment est une manière de
faire monter l'audience je vais vous
prendre un exemple la semaine dernière
la préfecture de police attendait 100
000 manifestants dont mille casseurs
donc visuellement ça donne ça c'est à
dire que les casseurs étaient ultra
minoritaires ils étaient 1% donc c'était
uniquement ce petit point noir et bien
toute l'après midi les chaînes d'infos
n'ont filmé que ce petit point noir
parce qu'évidemment à défaut de faire
monter l'audience en tout cas ça
maintient en quelque sorte l'audience
mais ce que je voulais aussi préciser
c'est que la violence ça n'est pas que
dans la rue il est aussi dans le débat
public on sait que ça se passe beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux ou il faut
respecter deux critères il faut être
bref et percutant donc bref c'est les
punchlines percutant c'est du clash mais
quelle est la forme orale qui est à la
fois la plus brève et la plus percutante
c'est l'insulte et donc évidemment sans
surprise souvenez-vous l'an dernier je
cite cet exemple voilà un député insulté
en direct
à la télévision donc oui il y a tout un
climat qui qui favorise la violence et
si bien qu'on en arrive à ce que je
disais au départ est-ce qu'il
regrettable c'est que on a l'impression
qu'il faut être violent pour se faire
entendre et un truc qui m'a moi amusé on
va dire pour employer un euphémisme
c'est quand Apolline de Malherbe était à
deux doigts d'engueuler Laurent Berger
en lui disant mais dites donc vous
seriez pas un peu mou du genou vous on
écoute est-ce que vous êtes pas trop
sage est-ce que le problème c'est que si
sages que finalement vous revendiquez
une manifestation qui se passe dans le
calme et c'est tout à fait le cas et
tout le monde l'observe mais au fond
est-ce que du coup dans le cas vous
arrivez à les faire plier c'est la vraie
sujet de la période mais ça c'est un
sujet qui dépasse le seul sujet des
retraites c'est vous savez la
mobilisation la plus importante dans les
rues au moment du mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'est 284 000 personnes selon la
police
alors voyez qu'en 300 000 violents
obtiennent 17 milliards de gouvernements
tandis que des millions de manifestants
pacifiques obtiennent une fin de nos
recevoir je suis contre la violence mais
comme ça pose des questions merci
excellent billet ce soir merci Stéphane
Frédéric ganski on voit de toute façon
là c'est très clair la violence elle est
dans le pays on l'a vu à Sainte Soline
on le voit dans les cortèges sur les
retraites mais celles contre les élus
elle date pas de cette crise là on a
l'impression qu'elle est un peu banale
qu'est-ce qui vous est arrivé vous
précisément et comment on encaisse ce
qui m'est arrivé moi il y a ma
permanence il y a mes équipes donc c'est
de retrouver trois fois le lendemain
d'une nuit donc au petit matin donc mes
collaborateurs qui sont arrivés à la
permanence avec donc des mots d'abord
contre le la réforme des retraites et
puis sur la dernière fois donc une
montée un petit peu en puissance des
menaces et également des simulations de
traces de sang donc avec avec de la
couleur rouge voilà donc bon c'est mes
collaborateurs qui ont découvert ça donc
c'est vrai que c'est pour eux c'est une
violence de découvrir cette attaque le
matin et donc voilà ce qui s'est passé
quoi à chaque fois donc
on porte plainte j'imagine
à protéger ses équipes bien sûr ça c'est
quand même la prioritable absolue parce
que moi je me suis engagé en politique
j'ai recruté des collaborateurs qui
viennent travailler à mes côtés au
service de mes idées mais qui
sont là pour m'accompagner donc voilà on
pense on pense à eux et puis ensuite on
essaye effectivement de faire en porte
plainte et on confie
ces sujets aux autorités policières et
judiciaires
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a dit est-ce que
vous avez la sentiment d'être un peu
soutenu ou finalement les gens ils
trouvent ça banal non j'ai beaucoup de
messages de soutien on m'a dit bon
courage sur le marché voilà on
m'accompagne quand même et beaucoup même
dans ces dans ces démarches là donc ça
c'est quand même plutôt rassurant
c'est voilà les gens sont globalement
globalement derrière nous quoi Laetitia
vient rappelez-nous vous ce que vous
avez subi
sur les cinq dernières années donc mes
cinq années de mandat j'ai déposé 16
plaintes alors je pouvais recevoir
quotidiennement sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment des messages d'injures souvent
de l'injure raciste lorsque j'ai décidé
de déposer plainte lorsque je sentais
qu'on dépassait un certain niveau ou que
je sentais ma vie potentiellement en
danger lorsqu'il y avait des menaces de
mort ou des messages d'incitation au
suicide particulièrement précis c'est à
chaque fois il y a une crise qui met en
cause le gouvernement les gilets jaunes
la crise sanitaire ou pas forcément
on a eu un certain nombre de crises au
cours du dernier mandat donc c'est vrai
que ça a été quelque chose d'assez
récurrent et durant la crise sanitaire
aussi j'ai pu en recevoir après moi
j'étais porte-parole de la majorité donc
très présente sur les plateaux et donc
c'est vrai que je pouvais recevoir ça en
réponse aussi à mes prises de parole et
donc à mes positions et c'est là qu'on
arrive dans une situation particulière
c'est que on venait pas m'attaquer sur
ce que je disais on était pas sur sur
une critique de fond une critique
politique mais sur ma personne puisque
la plupart des messages et des menaces
de morts que j'ai reçues étaient à
caractère raciste ouais on va y revenir
et les réseaux sociaux ont un rôle à la
fois sur l'anonymat et sur la caisse de
résonance que que la violence assure les
réseaux Jean garrigue l'historien le
phénomène il est nouveau ou pas du tout
n'a pas existé on pourrait en retrouver
un peu la trace au moment de la guerre
d'Algérie avec des plasticages etc
auxquels se livrait l'os mais
véritablement cette prise comme ça en
charge en compte des élus y compris des
élus de terrain c'est à dire des élus
locaux maintenant on a eu un maire qui
s'est fait tuer il y a pas très
longtemps c'est quelque chose quand même
qui est qui exprime une nouvelle
violence dans le dans l'espace public et
de spécifiquement français vous diriez
parce qu'on pense à l'héritage
révolutionnaire qui est quand même notre
ADN politique d'une certaine manière ça
c'est encore autre chose parce que c'est
c'est la tendance à se révolter contre
le la verticalité du pouvoir mais la
révolte contre la verticalité du pouvoir
ne passe pas forcément par la violence
la preuve le mouvement syndical nous a
donné l'exemple de quelque chose
d'extrêmement Pacifique organisé et qui
pouvait quand même faire passer un
message puisque plus des deux tiers des
Français le suivent là ce qui se passe
c'est quelque chose de
d'incontrôler mais qui traduit
évidemment comme toujours
sociologiquement une violence
sous-jacente de dans l'ensemble des
couches de la société avec des couches
nouvelles je veux dire des couches qui
sont nouvellesment entrées dans le dans
la vie publique gilet jaune c'était des
gens qu'on voyait jamais ce mobiliser
qui sont entrés dans le dans le débat
comme ça et ils l'ont fait avec les
instruments je dirais les plus immédiats
les plus spontanés pas au début des
gilets jaunes c'était très très calme
mais il s'est passé ensuite une
radicalisation une brutalisation de la
République parce que précisément ils
n'ont pas les structures d'encadrement
les moyens les habitudes si vous voulez
qui sont celles par exemple des
syndicats alors de quoi l'élu est-il le
nom c'est la question philosophique dans
cette flambée de violence Jean-Baptiste
Julia je précise qu'évidemment c'est la
majorité qui est principalement ciblée
mais pas seulement il y a eu aussi des
députés de gauche des députés de droite
je pense qu'ils vont commencer par
distinguer ce dont madame a témoigner à
savoir l'expression pure de la haine qui
absolument détestable et de l'autre côté
ce qui est intéressant c'est lorsque
l'argument de la violence relève d'une
stratégie et là on retrouve trois
arguments vous avez d'abord
effectivement l'argument de l'efficacité
je vais être violent parce que je
constate que ça marche ce qui est
extrêmement discutable puisqu'il faut
regarder le court terme et le moyen
terme ensuite vous avez l'argument de
l'épuisement des voies de recours
j'aimerais bien de ne pas être violent
mais après avoir tout essayé mais on
sait que les moyens sont nombreux en
démocratie parfois il y a une urgence de
résultats et bien je vais m'en remettre
à la violence et enfin vous avez un
argument très important qui est celui de
la responsabilité ou de l'origine de la
violence je suis violent mais ma
violence est une réaction à une violence
que j'ai subi une forme de violence
d'État si on qualifie le 49-3 de
violence ce qui à mon sens et discutable
on peut le critiquer sans dire que c'est
une violence et bien on donne un
argument à ceux qui vont se dire les
élus qui n'ont pas voté le texte mais
qui sont complices de ne pas avoir voté
effectivement la motion de censure vont
pouvoir être
renversés par la violence puisqu'il
participe d'un phénomène de violence et
c'est là que les mots sont essentiels on
peut émettre des critiques sur des
actions politique sans dire qu'elles
sont violentes parce que sinon on risque
de nourrir des discours qui vont
justifier après une violence qui peut
être à la base irrationnelle en
apportant effectivement de l'eau au
moulin de la violence alors c'est très
intéressant et je vous donne la parole
après à zinabè Chaouche c'est que dans
votre liste d'arguments on retrouve on
les retrouve dans la bouche des Français
comment Justine cette violence contre
les élus Marco pommier et Arnaud
Paillard ont suivi un député de la
majorité Renaissance qui est rompu au
contact de terrain reportage sur le
marché dans les Yvelines avec Carl Lee
regardez
car l'olive un député menacé à deux
reprises cette semaine sa venue dans
certains médias parisiens a fait l'objet
d'une surveillance policière ce jeudi
séjour de marché à Poissy comme
d'habitude le député de la majorité
déambulent entre les étals mais sans
appréhension je considère que la peur
est pas le danger c'est une minorité
encore une fois qui vient polluer
l'immense majorité de celles et ceux qui
veulent que la France avance et avancée
dans le pays c'est pour moi discuter
avec les gens échanger prendre des
bourpifs être apporté d'engueulade comme
on dit parce que je pense que c'est ça
qui fait avancer la France et c'est
certainement pas se planquer car l'olive
et l'ancien maire de la ville alors ici
l'accueil est plutôt chaleureux
qu'est-ce que je peux prendre comme
comme type d'olive pour mettre avec le
poulet je vais avoir des cuisses de
poulet là bien sûr la réforme des
retraites
occupe les esprits mais les riverains
que nous avons rencontrés condamnent les
menaces
par contre par contre il faut aussi
écouter un peu le
peuple le terrain quand j'étais maire de
Poissy j'avais des menaces qui étaient
autrement plus virulentes encore que
celle que j'ai eu avec des gens qui se
sont déplacés à la maison d'aujourd'hui
il y a aucune raison d'avoir des il n'y
a aucune raison d'avoir des menaces
soit on joue le jeu soit c'est tout mais
il y a aucune raison d'avoir des de
menacer qui que ce soit ça sert à rien
des Français qui désapprouvent les
insultes les intimidations et les
permanences dégradées de ces derniers
jours mais ces menaces sont-elles
compréhensibles certains s'interrogent
comme Arlette est-ce que vous comprenez
qu'on en arrive là parce que les
changements
ça allait insulter menacer les élus
je ne collecte dans le Nord que ça son
domicile a été emmuré non mais il faut
on marche sur la tête non c'est pas ça
la France
mais la France est très en colère la
colère de certains qui pointe du doigt
le manque d'écoute d'Emmanuel Macron
malgré les menaces car l’olive lui
continuera d'aller sur le terrain pour
dialoguer et appeler aux sursauts
républicains
on justifie pas mais on comprend quand
même ils l'ont un peu cherché c'est ça
qu'on entend on nous entend pas il y a
de la colère et finalement il finissent
par récolter ce qu'ils ont semé ça vous
le voyez vous montez oui notamment lors
des manifestations des grandes
manifestations j'en ai pas mal à couvert
récemment et là nouveauté notamment
depuis le 49-3 c'est des manifestants on
va dire pacifices des familles des qui
n'ont rien de gilet jaune on va dire
très actif ou des Black Blocs de
première ligne et bien c'est
manifestants pacifiste c'est la première
fois que je voulais ça accepter ou
ne se désolidariser pas de des violences
c'est-à-dire qu'avant il y avait ce
quand même ce mouvement
un petit peu de recul dire non mais là
vous êtes en train de salir nos slogans
notre mouvement social on va perdre en
crédibilité on va le radicaliser là j'ai
l'impression que c'est malheureusement
c'est un peu l'héritage Emmanuel Macron
qui a laissé sur le mouvement social et
contestataire c'est de faire accepter la
radicalité
monsieur madame tout le monde et on
voyait même des des gens s'habituer et
contourner les points les points chauds
acceptés de se faire un peu gazer et
enfin des gens avec des enfants qui a
accepté cette violence et moi c'est
cette acceptation en fait de la violence
qui je trouve est un peu inquiétante
quand même en tout cas elle est nouvelle
dans les manifestations actuelles oui je
suis complètement d'accord avec ça parce
que les violences qu'on a connues
mettons pendant les années 30 c'était
des violences de entre militants et
militants communistes d'un côté le
mi-temps d'extrême droite de l'autre et
ça se tapait dessus là c'est quelque
chose qui est en train d'imprégner la
société française qui est pris comme
quelque chose finalement de d'habituel
une banalisation sur la
correspondabilité moi je parlerai plutôt
de co-responsabilité il est certain que
la manière dont Emmanuel Macron a géré
cette cette crise et peut-être même
avant cette verticalité là elle a elle
est pour beaucoup dans dans leur
ras-le-bol de beaucoup de Français sur
fond de crises
elle permet d'excuser évidemment elle ne
peut pas justifier la violence et
j'ajouterai et pour c'est pour rebondir
ce qui a été dit c'est que il y a des
mots et une utilisation du mot violence
par certains alors là par des opposants
à Emmanuel Macron je pense
essentiellement à ceux qui ont une
stratégie de conflictualité c'est à dire
la France insoumise qui eux aussi
jettent des braises sur le feu de
l'huile sur le feu si vous voulez c'est
vrai que le climat voilà politique on
l'a vu dans le débat sur l'air traite
des deux côtés il y en a plein pour
rattraper l'autre c'est j'ose dire vous
avez les bras d'honneur de du ministre
de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti et vous avez les
mots à sa fin qui sont prononcés à
l'encontre du ministre du Travail par
les par les insoumises climat là il
autorise le passage à l'acte rien
n'autorise cette violence et je pense
que qu'il faut être extrêmement vigilant
ne jamais trouver le moyen de légitimer
cela et de banaliser donc là on
entendait dans le reportage des par
contre tout à l'heure dans la chronique
on a entendu ce petit mais on entend
vous même lorsque vous avez commencé
l'émission vous avez ajouté ce et le 49
n'arrange pas les choses à chaque fois
lorsque l'on fait le lien entre
un débat politique et la violence on est
en train de justifier cela et donc de
d'entraîner cet acceptation au sein de
la société bien sûr que certains n'ont
concitoyens peuvent être contre le 49-3
et bien sûr que il y a aujourd'hui une
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et une mobilisation distincte
concernant 49 quand même Jean Gary
explique que la verticalité du pouvoir
avec toutes les procédures
constitutionnelles utilisées sur ce
débat retraite vous n'y voyez aucune
forme comment dire de pas de
responsabilité mais d'autorisation ou
attiser de la part du pouvoir sur la
société c'est la question que je vous
pose est-ce que l'usage des outils
démocratiques est une forme
d'autorisation à la violence
il y a eu aussi le je mets évidemment
beaucoup de de guillemets les
comportements policiers avec plein
d'interpellations et beaucoup
d'interpellations et relâcher les gens
rapidement 100 poursuites et ça aussi ça
a utilisé un petit peu un sentiment pas
de revanche ou de chez Jean mais en tout
cas d'injustice et c'est vrai que ça
aussi il y a eu sur le terrain des
comportements qui ont pu un peu agacer
de mon écran de télévision mais ce qu'on
a pu appeler les arrestations
préventives démenties par le préfet on
sent qu'il y a un climat de tension
c'est vrai et et c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est dans ces moments là où
il y a un climat de tension exacerbé
qu'il faut d'autant plus se redoubler de
vigilance alors et d'autant plus
s'assurer de ne pas justifier légitimer
cela parce que sinon je c'est un effet
boule de neige je voudrais qu'on avance
un peu sur les le sursaut sur sur les
solutions Frédéric ginsky on entend
beaucoup dire qui est une forme de
faussée de divorce entre les élus et le
peuple les représentants et les Français
est-ce que vous vous voyez ça est-ce que
une manière de peut-être apaisée ce
serait de donner un peu plus de pouvoir
de participation des citoyens à la
décision je crois que d'abord c'est déjà
beaucoup au niveau local et qu'il faut
l'amplifier voilà il faut aussi qui est
un certain renouvellement de la classe
politique moi-même je me suis engagé ces
Bérengère Couillard donc ce que tu as
été écologique qui m'a proposé d'être
son suppléant et donc je suis venu en
politique en étant simple conseiller
municipal d'opposition d'ailleurs assez
SAS donc je pratique aussi l'opposition
constructive et voilà dès que je suis
pas d'accord avec le maire où je suis
élu je veux pas casser la mairie vous
voyez donc il y a on vit quand même dans
un état droit dans une dans une
démocratie dans un état de droit avec
une liberté d'expression il y a eu
peut-être des violences policières mais
il y a des enquêtes qui sont en cours la
justice va va faire son son œuvre et
donc voilà il faut il faut rappeler
toujours ces institutions rappeler dans
quel environnement il évolue et dire aux
gens qu'ils ont la possibilité de
s'engager en politique et de faire
changer les choses comme ça quoi pendant
les gilets jaunes il y a eu aussi
la demande démocratique c'était le
fameux Rick est-ce qu'il faut l'entendre
ça alors la question effectivement
est-ce que ce à quoi on assiste c'est un
agression contre la démocratie
représentative moi je n'en suis pas sûr
parce que déjà je n'entends pas les
demandes de Rick revenir bon il y a la
question du référendum initiative
partagée mais qui est quand même
différent et puis on voit bien par
exemple que la France insoumise la nuit
pèse qui sont effectivement des élus
contestataires incarnent aussi très bien
le parlementaire et effectivement je
pense que il faut distinguer au sens ils
incarnent la représentation
beaucoup plus qu'il y a une meilleure
est-ce qu'il y a une bonne
représentation et est-ce que les élus
ont suffisamment de pouvoir et d'outils
pour faire en sorte que les intérêts des
Français soient entendus et là je pense
qu'il y a une discussion qu'on peut
avoir mais qui doit se faire totalement
en dehors de l'usage de la violence donc
je suis pas sûr effectivement qu'il
faille au-delà de la dimension
insurrectionnelle qui est à mon sens et
minoritaire pensait que tout cela serait
le signe d'une demande urgente de
nouvelles révisions constitutionnelles
il y en a pas eu depuis 2008 peut-être
que ce sera un sujet amené par le
Président de la République public mais à
mon sens c'est pas la seule solution
pour faire taire la violence puisqu'il y
a d'autres éléments qui sont on parle de
respiration démocratique ça peut être le
citoyen associé à la décision on la voit
avec la convention citoyenne sur la fin
de vie là qui va rendre ses conclusions
ça peut être le référendum aussi il y a
pas de Mistigri pour sortir de cette
déconnexion entre les acteurs politiques
et les élus mais il faut la regarder en
face elle existe d'ailleurs le je dirais
le président du parti dont vous êtes
député je pense avec conseillé c'est un
secret personne à Emmanuel Macron
pratiqué un petit peu moins de
verticalité dans cette crise parce que
c'est un homme politique qui connaît
la vie politique justement qui est une
expérience et je pense qu'il y aurait
géré les choses un peu un peu
différemment mais passons ça c'est un
des aspects du problème
il semblerait malgré tout que dans
toutes les d'ailleurs dans toutes les
démocraties et notamment dans la nôtre
qui est schizophrène c'est-à-dire que on
a besoin de cette verticalité du pouvoir
c'est l'élection présidentielle c'est
les pouvoirs qu'on confère à des espèces
d'hommes providentialité qui tous les
jours
je le pense mais en même temps on a
justement ce tropisme de qui vient de la
Révolution française de cette démocratie
participative du contrôle citoyen et il
me semble que dans l'exercice de des
institutions de la 5ème République
depuis notamment depuis la fameuse
révision de 2000 le couplage des deux
élections on sait on a
surprésidentialiser c'est l'usage de ces
institutions je pense que la conception
jupiterienne n'a pas arrangé les choses
et je pense qu'on pourrait essayer de
trouver ne serait-ce que dans
l'application de ces institutions dans
un rééquilibrage des pouvoirs un peu
plus de pouvoir au Premier ministre et
le premier gouverne vraiment et le
président arbitre qui donne l'impression
qui donne l'impression aux Français que
ce président de la République n'est pas
un monarque républicain il ne l'est pas
en réalité il est il correspond et
l'usage du 49-3 ça fait partie de
l'arsenal le parlementarisme rationalisé
c'est institutionnel Sénégal mais pour
les Français ça n'est plus accepté il
faut en tenir compte vous avez une
liberté de parole vous êtes plus députés
la République en marche il a pas un peu
raison Jean Gary vous avez pas souffert
d'une forme voilà de verticalité
d'isolement de toute puissance du
président de la République dans la
précédente législature moi je pense que
notre démocratie elle a besoin d'un
nouveau souffle et que notre arrivée en
responsabilité à l'époque en 2017 était
déjà alors est-ce que c'était un
symptôme une résultante je ne sais plus
aujourd'hui mais de ce besoin de
complètement revoir aussi le
fonctionnement nos institutions et en
effet redonner davantage de souffle et
de parole aux citoyens et et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu énormément de tentatives de
concertation de consultation mais en
fait notre démocratie elle est peut-être
pas faite non plus pour ça par exemple
la grande époque du grand débat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait infini de tous ces
cahiers de doléances on a c'est pas
prévu dans institutionnelle des regrets
sur ça on n'a pas assez regardé on n'a
pas assez utilisé ces résultats des
doléances on a moi par exemple j'en
organisé 12 grands débats sur ma
circonscription à l'époque et ça m'a
alimenté mais à ma petite échelle
ensuite dans ma fonction parlementaire
mais cette grosse machine qui est la
démocratie française et bien en effet
elle a cette difficulté à lui redonner
et à faire tout cela je voudrais qu'on
parle juste des réseaux sociaux c'était
votre texte parce que on l'a vu c'est
aussi un moyen de les réseaux sociaux de
lancer des raids sur des personnes on a
retrouvé des des adresses de domicile
sur des groupes Facebook notamment
pendant les gilets jaunes aujourd'hui
les plateformes suppriment ça très vite
avec cette loi pas suffisamment vite
c'est ça le problème aussi et c'est ça
aussi qui qui fait qu'on est en train de
porter attendre de manière assez
profonde à notre démocratie on parlait
tout à l'heure de la question de la
démocratie représentative qui a
aujourd'hui envie de représenter nos
concitoyens quand on sait à quoi on
s'expose quand on sait à quoi on expose
d'habitude nos familles également on
parlait tout à l'heure du domicile de
violet speed Bull moi je peux vous dire
que ma mère m'a appelé récemment il m'a
dit que elle était bien contente que je
ne sois pas réélu parce que sinon ça
leur est mise en situation de tension
durant toute cette période parce que oui
ce qu'on vit sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est un continuum de violence c'est
numérique et ça devient et ça devient
physique et il y a des études qui ont
été faites récemment notamment aux
Etats-Unis et qui montre d'ailleurs que
ce sujet est pas juste français mais
qu'on a aussi une crise de la
représentation parce que justement quand
on sait à quoi on s'expose et à quel
niveau les personnes sont sont exposées
à une violence notamment les femmes et
bien on a de moins en moins de personnes
qui ont envie de brider un mandat et
est-ce qu'on peut leur reprocher ça
quand on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui plus personne ne voudra
s'engager en politique et d'être
d'accord c'est le risque c'est le risque
mais après sur les réseaux sociaux donc
on a deux types de dérive la première
qui qui est celle de de se voir pointer
du doigt par certains collègues pour
certains votes bon moi personnellement
j'assume mes votes donc voilà donc
ouvrir de honte en disant il n'a pas
voté il n'a pas voté le glyphosate par
exemple l'interdiction quand on parle
pas des votes mais on parle l'autre jour
on avait la vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale donc Elodie
Jacquie Laforge qui a eu une guillotine
mise sous son nom là c'est plus choquant
et donc par contre je tiens à dire qu'on
est intervenu auprès de Twitter au
niveau des collègues du groupe
Démocratie ils ont supprimé le débat aux
États-Unis par exemple pour carrément
interdire Tik Tok à l'échelle du pays
est-ce que c'est une solution ou pas une
question éducative il faut retrouver
aussi des principes communs je pense
qu'il y a une confusion entre le respect
et l'estime ce que Pascal le philosophe
distinguait ce qu'on doit aux élus aux
personnes qui sont destinotorité c'est
un respect par exemple le salut
républicain mais en revanche on n'est
pas tenu effectivement de les estimer
mais l'absence d'estime lui faites pas à
partager les idées ça doit aussi
s'exprimer dans des formes effectivement
il y a autre chose que l'insulte pour
exprimer une des approbation et là
effectivement il y a plusieurs problèmes
sur les réseaux sociaux qui tiennent
aussi à l'anonymat on peut penser qu'il
peut y avoir aussi une dimension
cathartique on peut espérer que des
personnes qui se défoule n'iront pas
jusqu'à franchir le pas physiquement
donc on peut aussi en douter c'est là
que c'est effectivement très inquiétant
le sursaut on sent bien que il va
falloir réparer on parle de crise
démocratique on parle des soufflements
de la démocratie représentative on parle
de crise institutionnelle qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on va faire comment
comment on fait on est beaucoup à
réfléchir chacun dans son coin au dessus
parce que c'est une responsabilité
collective
ne serait-ce que le réapprentissage de
la citoyenneté de ce que c'est la
pédagogie de la citoyenneté c'est
quelque chose qui qui est un urgent
besoin aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les
gens s'applient très bien ce que c'est
d'appartenir à un collectif comme ça de
citoyens on le voit bien sinon justement
ils iraient pas dans ces dans ces dans
ces formes de violences mentalité le
civisme en somme mais évidemment le
civisme il s'apprend je dirais par le
haut c'est-à-dire que il faut que nos
élus prennent l'exemple montre l'exemple
un comportablement manifestement
qui a des limites je le répète que ça
soit du côté de l'exécutif de
l'opposition etc on voit bien que on est
encore dans cette conception de rapport
de force extrêmement brutaux de de
conflits de clash etc moi-même hier j'ai
reçu un dans les réseaux sociaux un
poignard ensanglanté je suis quoi un
observateur comme ça parmi d'autres de
la vie publique on voit bien qu'il y a
quelque chose aujourd'hui qui est en
train d'insecter le débat public et je
je répète donner des signes d'apaisement
à ce débat public notamment quand on est
au sommet de l'État en haut de la
pyramide je pense que ce serait une
bonne inspiration c'est pas la crise que
vous êtes d'accord vous êtes ici à via
pardonne-moi juste un mot rapidement
pour dire que réapprendre à débattre
c'est aussi
changer notre façon notre rapport sur
les sur les réseaux sociaux sur Internet
où on a quand même aujourd'hui des
outils qui valorisent une parole brutale
non nuancée des propos de 10 secondes
maximum lorsqu'il s'agit de vidéo et
donc c'est ça aussi mais aujourd'hui
avec cette loi valorisation en tapant
aux porte-monnaie les plateformes c'est
ça que vous faites au niveau européen
aussi 6% du chiffre d'affaires des
plateformes qui qui peut être prononcé
face à ses comportements mais c'est
aussi une question d'éducation parce que
ce qui est demandé aux plateformes de
supprimer c'est ce qui est de
l'agressivité la plus crasse et évidente
et ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un peu plus
profond au sein de la société des
réseaux sociaux vous avez peut-être vu
la Une de Libération ce matin la
profiteuse je vous laisse deviner Marine
Le Pen c'est ça qui est en train de se
passer une grosse partie de mon temps
une certaine partie de mon temps elle
est dans les écoles dans les écoles
primaires dans des lycées professionnels
hier j'étais dans un lycée professionnel
pour explique non pas pour convertir
tout le monde au centrisme mais pour
expliquer ce qu'est la citoyenneté ce
qu'est la République ce qu'est la
démocratie et voilà je pense que tout le
monde enfin en tout cas les gens qui
sont engagés dans la vie publique ils
devraient aussi passer du temps à cette
mission et ben écoutez merci on va
s'arrêter là le chantier est immense et
voilà il faudra sûrement beaucoup de
temps pour réussir à à recoudre le tissu
du débat public merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu débattre sur ce plateau vous
restez avec moi à Zina Mel Chaouche dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis au féminin vous les
voyez ce soir Isabelle Lasserre nous
parle de Donald Trump qui est inculpé
par la justice c'est une première mais
pas forcément empêché pour la suite
pause c'est le mot de la semaine de
Mariette darrigran après la proposition
de Laurent Berger de suspendre la
réforme des retraites et puis bataille
de commission d'enquêtes sur Sainte
Soline à l'Assemblée nationale ce sera
dans Bourbon express avec Stéphanie
desperres mais d'abord on va parler un
peu de vous à Chaouche et de ce dossier
V13 primé je le disais par le jury du
Livre politique ce qu'il faut savoir de
la plus grande audience criminelle
organisée en France et dans ce livre on
voit cela avec l'invitation de Marion
Becker et on en parle tous les deux
juste après
si on vous invite à zine Ahmed Chaouche
c'est parce que vous venez de recevoir
le Prix étudiant du Livre politique avec
le dessinateur Valentin Pasquier pour
votre roman graphique dossier V13 du nom
du procès historique des attentats du 13
novembre vous avez couvert les 10 mois
de ce procès hors norme 1800 parties
civils 1300 blessés 330 avocats et 20
accusés
karazdina melchaouche vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation aujourd'hui
reportèrent à quotidien après avoir
débuté au Parisien tu as M6 vous aviez
déjà enquêté sur l'islamisme radical
avec la France du Jihad cette fois vous
faites le récit du procès des attentats
du 13 novembre 2015 un travail de
mémoire entreprise avec Valentin
Pasquier dessinateur judiciaire pour
France Inter le Parisien France votre
plume sont très de crayon vous avez
sélectionné des jours-clés du procès
vous décrivez les différents visages de
saladeslam l'accusé le plus emblématique
tour à tour distance muet revendicative
l'émotion est palpable quand vous narez
la semaine pendant laquelle 200 victimes
se succèdent à la barre des témoignages
aussi poignants que traumatisant mais
parfois teinté d'une pointe d'humour
comme une forme de mise à distance de
cet événement sans précédent ce sont 10
mois de débats et d'émotions de justice
que vous retracez alors on vous pose la
question azzdin Ahmed Chaouch pour vous
le journaliste expérimenté ce procès
restera-t-il comme l'expérience la plus
forte de votre carrière
réponse à ce dynama Chaouche très bonne
question c'est toujours difficile de
garder un événement mais oui alors
malheureusement ça a commencé dès le 13
novembre j'aimerais dire ce que je
suivais cette actualité criminelle
puisque j'étais spécialiste police comme
on dit mais oui c'était c'est dix mois
oui on sort pas indemne
on avait pourtant des des psy qui était
à disposition plus pour les parties
civils et les familles mais les
journalistes ont on avait ce droit
d'aller consulter mais par un peu fierté
de journaliste puis on sentait prêt mais
alors en fin de compte on n'était pas
prêt on a eu des moments où certains
enfin moi ça m'est arrivé de sécher
quelques jours notamment lors des cinq
semaines de témoignages de partie civil
ou un moment c'était difficile qu'est-ce
qui vous a le plus marqué dans cette
cette longue
liste de témoignages qui qui se
succèdent les familles qui témoignent
les victimes
laisser les rescapés des terrasses celle
du Bataclan quel témoignage vous a le
plus touché on les voit là c'est parti
civils elles avaient le le badge avec le
fil rouge
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a le
plus marqué de tous ces récits vous
imaginez choisir parmi tous ces
témoignages toutes ces vies brisés
parfois alors j'aime dans ce flot de
d'histoire tragique de personnes qui
n'ont rien demandé et qui se retrouvent
du jour au lendemain
sans
sans enfants en perdant une compagne en
compagnon une mère ou un père j'aime
garder peut-être un ou deux moments
presque positif comme ce témoignage
d'une rescapée de la belle équipe
qui organise son anniversaire la belle
équipe cette terrasse rue Charonne dans
le 11e arrondissement et qui elle
s'est vu
a été victime de cette attaque à
laquelle kalachnikov elle est
aujourd'hui handicapée à vie elle voit
l'un de ses meilleurs amis mourir devant
elle mais qui malgré ça a commis je
dirais a fait une erreur qui a permis de
sauver la vie de
beaucoup de ses amis parce qu'elle a
envoyé pour son anniversaire rendez-vous
à la belle époque parce que son son
téléphone a mal retranscrit donc il y a
la moitié de ses copains qui sont allés
à la belle époque dans un autre
arrondissement
donc il y a aussi ces histoires là ce
qui est génial dans le livre c'est on
vit le procès à la fois avec vous vous
l'expliquer d'ailleurs c'est assez
pédagogique pour les plus jeunes
notamment mais vous nous faites
ressentir les choses que vous vivez en
même temps et les dessins sont
formidables et remarquables Valentin
Pasquier je redis c'est essentiel c'est
dessin partagent ce prix avec vous alors
il travailler lui pour d'autres médias
que quotidien France Inter notamment
comment comment vous avez fait pour
mettre ensemble vos travaux respectifs
c'est vrai que déjà le comment est ce
projet c'est en étant sur place tous les
jours pour quotidien j'avais une en fait
une matière assez importante mais je
devais en garder enfin vous le savez ici
mais 3 minutes quand il y avait de la
place mais on avait ce parti pris d'en
parler quasiment tous les jours dans le
quotidien mais donc il y avait une
frustration du journaliste qui avait le
sentiment de vivre à un moment
d'histoire fort et donc j'ai eu cette
idée d'en faire un livre donc avec
l'éditrice lisboel qui s'est dit mais il
faut quand même le le
gravé dans le marbre de manière encore
plus visuelle mais comme par définition
dans un procès il y a aucune photo
aucune vidéo le dessin presse nous
paraissait la manière la plus évidente
de ça se et donc et quand j'ai vu les
dessins de Valentin donc dans
Ouest-France le Parisien même sur le
site de France Inter j'ai vu ce que moi
j'avais vu en fait en réel c'est à dire
et garder les couleurs
il acceptait de dessiner un méchant
accusé beau parce que il était beau ou
triste parce qu'il était triste alors
justement on va en voir des dessins on
va commencer par le président du
tribunal le juge Jean-Louis perriès qui
est graine on s'en souvient même si on
n'était pas forcément dans la salle
d'audience le nom des 85 victimes tués
au Bataclan pour ouvrir le procès on le
voit ici on a beaucoup dit que c'était
le procès de sa vie et terminer sa
carrière comment présider-il alors c'est
c'était le personnage
clé qui a fait de ce procès selon moi
une qui en a fait une réussite pénale
le premier jour on est l'illustration la
plus spectaculaire salade des slam n'a
pas parlé pendant plus de 6 ans
d'instruction donc il y a une attente
énorme autour du principal accusé il se
lève et là en quelque sorte il est au
niveau de ce qu'on attendait lui
c'est-à-dire il se présente comme un
méchant djihadiste je suis combattant de
Allah il revendique là après quelques
minutes
dans son discours quelqu'un qui donnait
l'impression de d'écouter et donc il y
avait la question est-il en train de
tous nous manipuler ce qu'il a changé de
version de stratégie donnant
l'impression d'être un djihadiste dur
puis se défaussant expliquant que il
n'avait pas vous lu actionner sa
ceinture et prix de d'un moment
d'humanité c'est ce qu'il a dit puis il
sait renfermé une nouvelle fois dans le
silence puis la pleurer puis de
l'impression qu'il allait aider la
justice voilà donc on a une femme qui a
joué un rôle clé c'est son avocate
Olivia Renens c'est incroyable parce que
cette femme qui défend ce terroriste qui
décide que tout le monde a droit avec
défendre et donc de travailler avec lui
va rendre possible d'une certaine façon
sa sortie du silence et l'émergence du
vérité racontez-nous qui elle était et
comment ça s'est passé
l'une des révélations du procès avocat
peu connu médiatiquement
alors qui avait fait ces classes dans
notamment des affaires de de djihadisme
aussi de
d'assination à résidence pendant l'état
d'urgence elle commençait à se faire un
nom vous savez que c'était son premier
grand procès et il faut dire qu'elle a
été
bonne qu'elle a porté sa voix d'un point
de vue pénal alors c'est vrai que c'est
difficile à comprendre on associe
souvent quand on connaît pas la matière
pénale et justice on associe souvent un
client à son avocat on dit l'épouse de
la thèse non elle elle était là pour
défendre le droit et en quelque sorte de
donner à ce process qui laisse
d'ailleurs des réponses pénales et
surtout apporter nous ce qu'on attendait
une réponse démocratique à la barbarie
de daesh et elle a fait oui on pense
elle l'a fait sortir de son silence mais
à un moment donné on s'est posé la
question qui était en train de manipuler
qui avait pris le dessus sur qui parce
que quand il a commencé à changer de
version on s'est dit est-ce qu'elle a la
main dessus et c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'elle veut elle ou pas puisque quand
il commence à se présenter comme un
grand méchant terroriste j'imagine que
c'était pas la stratégie qu'elle
souhaitait c'est un procès qui a duré 9
mois qui a été entièrement filmé pour
les archives des historiens d'ailleurs
on peut consulter les images on peut
faire cette demande surtout pour
travailler de de l'histoire il y a un
chapitre qui s'appelle le son de la mort
l'audio a été aussi capté c'est le jour
8 jour redouté par les victimes
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce jour-là on
entend tout c'est le jour de
où on entend une partie
du son du Bataclan c'est un dictaphone
qui a été laissé par l'une des victimes
que les enquêteurs ont retrouvé
et c'était terrible parce que on n'a pas
entendu beaucoup parce qu'on est un
choix pour ne pas
imposer ça aux victimes aux parties
civiles mais on a le début du concert et
à cette musique se mêle les premiers
bruits de kalachnikov
et là c'était et ce qui était difficile
c'était d'imaginer justement sans avoir
l'image
et ce jour là l'enquêteur qui était
chargé de retranscrire cet audio parce
que tout n'a pas été diffusé il a joué
les djihadistes et pour que ce soit
crédible mais il fallait qu'il incarne
et dit à 10 donc il a mis l'intention
notamment quand l'un des djihadistes du
Bataclan justifie le mobile et qu'il dit
que c'est François Hollande qui était le
responsable en quelque sorte de ça là
c'était
très fort il y a aussi des des pages sur
la vie en fait la vie continue malgré
l'horreur de ce Prophet qui se tient en
plein covid il y a même la guerre qui va
s'inviter puisque février 2022 la Russie
invalide l'Ukraine et puis il y a la
place Dauphine la Place Dauphine et ce
café où les gens se croisent très
rapidement ça devient un lieu
incontournable il y a deux endroits en
fait il y a un endroit avant donc cette
place Dauphine voilà si toutes ces
terrasses notamment là je pense que
c'est le dernier jour peut-être en tout
cas le dernier jour il y a eu absolument
l'a pris dans cette scène incroyable
presque d'attente parce que on attendait
lors du verdict on savait pas à quelle
heure elle est tombée ce verdict ok il y
a une attente comme ça qui s'est
prolongée et dans une espèce de bonne
humeur comme dans un banquier de mariage
ou un vin d'honneur parce qu'en fait les
gens avaient créé enfin les participes
là qu'on voit avec leur collier orange
on retrouve oui et son crée une
communauté et quelque part c'était la
fin de ce moment de communion qui était
autour de l'horreur parce qu'on a on
allait parler de choses horribles mais
quelque part ces personnes étaient
devenu omi ou s'écrit pendant 9 mois un
rendez-vous où est partagé des choses
certains sont devenus amis et là en
quelque sorte il y avait la peur de cet
après c'était la fin arriver l'été aussi
il y avait comme une année civile qui
s'était qui s'arrêtait et on attendait
aussi sur tout le verdict de la cour
d'assise et puis il y avait aussi de
l'autre côté de la place boulevard du
Palais le bar la brasserie ou l'Est ou
si tout le monde se retrouve où les
accusés se retrouver enfin des et les
accusés qui comparaissaient libres se
retrouvaient à côté des victimes les
journalistes au milieu et on oublie un
moment et c'est aussi pour dire que la
justice c'était dans le palais de
justice et autour pour devenir tous des
procès qui n'a pas fini d'être raconté
tant il a été danse dossier maîtresse
chez plomb avec Valentin Pasquier au
dessin regardez Les Affranchis vont nous
rejoindre et vous allez pouvoir réagir à
leur chronique c'est les parties pris
tout de suite on vous accueille les
filles allez-y mesdames
Isabelle Lasserre correspondant
diplomatique du Figaro bonsoir Isabelle
là c'est biologue Mariette darrigan et
son mot de la semaine bonsoir Mariette
installez-vous je vous donne la parole
dans 5 minutes mais on commence avec
Bourbon Express comme chaque soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir parce Stéphanie
Despierre bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir et
l'histoire du jour c'est l'histoire
d'une course à la commission d'enquête
après les violences affrontements à
sainte-solines autour d'une retenue
d'eau ce n'est pas encore officiel mais
des députés de la majorité veulent
déposer une commission d'enquête sur les
événements du week-end dernier elle
serait soutenue par les trois groupes
horizons modem Renaissance et porté par
Aurore berger la chef députée macroniste
l'annonce devrait être faite en début de
semaine prochaine il s'agit d'enquêter
sur la structuration et l'organisation
des groupes muscules et des
manifestations illicites du mois de mars
ce serait une manière pour les troubles
d'Emmanuel Macron d’emboîter le pas au
gouvernement qui toute la semaine accusé
la gauche de contribuer au climat de
violence à la haine et accuser même les
insoumis de vouloir saper les
institutions et donc c'est une
commission d'enquête qui est un peu la
réponse à elle et fils c'est ça oui car
les insoumis ont dégainé les premiers
dès mardi les députés LFI ont dénoncé
les violences policières et annoncer
leur intention de demander une
commission d'enquête ils veulent
notamment faire la lumière sur les armes
qui ont été utilisées par les forces de
l'ordre le nombre de policiers le nombre
de blessés et évidemment les conditions
à d'accès des secours sur le site
seulement voilà la France insoumise a
épuisé ce qu'on appelle son droit de
tirage son droit à demander des enquêtes
parlementaires il n'y en a qu'un par
groupe et par session alors la
présidente des insoumis Mathilde de
panneaux demande à l'assemblée nationale
tout entière de reprendre sa proposition
au vu des du nombre de unes
internationales qui ont été faites sur
le sujet
au vu de la manière dont le monde est en
train de regarder la France et surtout
au vu de la gravité des blessés que nous
avons dans ce pays avec je le rappelle
deux personnes qui sont dans un coma
dont une et entre la vie et la mort je
pense que l'Assemblée nationale
sonnerait à donner donner lieu à cette
commission d'enquête
alors je précise que l'un des deux
manifestants très gravement blessés dont
par le Mathilde pano et depuis sortie du
coma pour en revenir à la commission
d'enquête il est presque improbable que
l'assemblée suive la demande de Mathilde
de panneau l'autre solution pour les
insoumis ce serait qu'un de leurs allées
de la nupes qui a encore un droit de
tirage reprenne cette idée à son compte
pour l'instant ni les socialistes ni les
communistes n'ont donné de signes en ce
sens un droit de tirage c'est précieux
dans la stratégie de chaque groupe
politique alors il ne faut surtout pas
le gaspiller du côté des écologistes
vont une réflexion est en cours certains
y sont favorables comme la députée
Sandrine
rousseaudre cette position au sein du
groupe écologiste dont je ne sais pas
encore quelle sera la décision je pense
que nous l'apprendrons mardi mais moi je
pousserai la position selon laquelle il
nous faut une commission d'enquête sur
la manière dont on est militants
écologiste sont traités il y a une
criminalité une criminalisation il y a
des mots comme éco-terroriste qui sont
utilisés mais derrière il y a aussi des
méthodes policières il y a aussi des
méthodes de surveillance qui sont
attentatoires à mon sens au droit de
l'homme donc on comprend que cette
commission d'enquête est très attendue
finalement par la gauche par la droite
par la majorité aussi oui mais avant il
y a un rendez-vous attendu deux pieds
ferme par les députés d'opposition de
droite et surtout de gauche vous l'aurez
compris un rendez-vous avec le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est mercredi à 9h en
commission des lois Gérald Darmanin sera
auditionné par les députés qui
l'interrogeront sur sa gestion du
maintien de l'ordre lors des dernières
manifestations vu les polémiques de ces
derniers jours vous aurez compris que
l'audition sera très suivie et elle sera
évidemment à suivre en direct sur la
chaîne parlementaire azzimet Chaouch et
commission d'enquête sur quelque chose
d'aussi compliqué mais qui est vraiment
central à la fois pour les Français la
question du maintien de l'ordre la
question des méga bassines la question
de des Black Blocs est-ce qu'il c'est à
l'Assemblée dans ce cadre-là qu'on
pourrait réussir à faire la lumière sur
ce qui s'est passé ou c'est plutôt la
justice je sais pas je pense que il y a
des sujets qui devraient être pris un
peu plus
sérieusement mais en tout cas qui
devrait être venir prioritaire comme
celui de la brave on en a pas parlé mais
pour la supprimer exactement je pense
que police mobile
des sujets aussi emblématiques et
visibles que ça que le gouvernement
pourrait marquer des points si voilà on
décidait de suspendre le temps peut-être
des manifestations et de la fin de la
Fronde autour de la réforme de retraite
voilà moi c'est vraiment sur cette
police là je pense que il y a un coup à
jouer pour le gouvernement du côté du
gouvernement vous n'ayez pas
personnellement Isabelle on enchaîne
vous nous parlez Donald Trump alors
c'est drôle parce que on a des sorcières
chefs d'État qui qui ont été voilà
devant la justice pénale mais c'est une
première pour un président un ancien
président américain je l'ai appris il va
être inculpé au pénal quelles
conséquences racontez-nous et oui c'est
la première fois et il va être inculpé
pour une banale à faire de mœurs c'est
un accord financier qu'il avait passé
avec une ancienne actrice du porno
stormy Daniels pour cacher une liaison
qui aurait eu avec elle a on s'attendait
en fait à ce que d'autres
des enquêtes débouche avant puisque
Trump est dans le comédie amateur de la
justice pour avoir incité à l'émeute du
6 janvier 2021 contre le Capitole pour
avoir tenté d'inverser les résultats de
l'élection
présidentielle en Géorgie ou pour avoir
conserver des documents classifiés alors
concrètement qu'est-ce qui va se passer
Donald Trump devrait se présenter mardi
devant la justice new-yorkaise qui
relèvera ses empreintes de demain mais
attention ce n'est sans doute pas cette
affaire qui va le mener directement en
prison comme l'espère de nombreux
démocrates ni cette affaire d'ailleurs
ni les autres ne devrait en théorie
l'empêcher de se représenter à
l'élection présidentielle en 2024 où il
est depuis quelques jours le favori de
la primaire républicaine lui qui prétend
être le seul à pouvoir empêcher la
troisième guerre mondiale apprenez un
ton beaucoup plus dur vis-à-vis de la
Chine et qui a souvent ménagé Vladimir
Poutine pour ne pas dire plus enfin
c'est tout un programme alors selon vous
ce que c'est inculpation va l'affaiblir
ou au contraire le renforcer alors c'est
la question à laquelle on peut pas
répondre parce qu'on ne peut pas préjugé
de des décisions de justice mais on peut
pas exclure non plus que les affaires
judiciaires de Donald Trump finissent
par jouer en sa faveur en tout cas lui
ont déjà offert un tremplin en quelque
sorte son premier meeting de campagne il
dénonce une chasse aux sorcières un con
un complot politique
organisé par cet état de de l'ombre qui
n'a eu de cesse de dénoncer il y a même
une levée de fond qui a été organisée au
sein de ses partisans qui sont dont
beaucoup appartiennent à des milieux
complotistes alors ce qu'il faut bien
voir quand même c'est que trois ans
après l'élection de Joe Biden il y a
toujours une partie de l'électorat de
Donald Trump une partie électorale plus
en fait les élus négationnistes du
Congrès qui croit toujours que le
scrutin a été volé et donc leur haine de
Joe Biden est tellement violente et des
démocrates que répond pas une ce n'est
pas une vulgaire à faire demeure ce qui
va en fait ternir l'image de de leur
héros eux qui n'ont plus confiance
depuis longtemps dans les institutions
fédérales c'est ça l'enjeu principal
pour les États-Unis c'est ça oui et non
parce que finalement enfin tout le monde
sait que Donald Trump n'est pas arrivé
par hasard à la Maison Blanche
aujourd'hui ces idées restent très
populaires au sein du parti républicain
et parmi les élus négationnistes alors
au Congrès et à la Chambre des
Représentants certains élèves ont même
dépassé leur maître comme cette
sulfureuse élue conspirationniste de
Georgie marjorité leur green qui est
aussi sécessionniste puisqu'elle prône
carrément un divorce national entre les
États démocrates et les états
républicains alors l'incubation de
Donald Trump est la manière dont elle
est commentée dans la classe politique
en fait ne font que nous rappeler l'état
d'extrême division de la société
américaine et la fracture énorme de ce
pays et ce pays est à ce point fracturé
que aujourd'hui de plus en plus le
statut du citoyen finit par dépendre de
l'état dans lequel vous vous habitez
c'est le cas par exemple à votre avec
l'avortement ou une femme n'a pas les
mêmes droits selon qu'elle habite
l'Illinois ou qu'elle est dans l'Ohio
donc tout ça ça rappelle un peu un petit
peu quand même les divisions de la
mairie que juste avant la guerre de
Sécession il y a 160 ans c'est terrible
merci merci Isabelle pas le temps de
vous faire réagir parce qu'on va faire
une petite pause sémantique avec vous
Mariette dari grand notre sémiologue
favorite dans cette émission la pose
c'est le mot de Laurent Berger pour
demander une suspension le temps de
revenir à la table de négociation sur la
forme des retraites
oui alors comme ça apparemment c'est un
mot très simple je vais pas vous faire
une grande étymologie ça m'arrive
parfois de faire un voyage culturel dans
un mot là non posa en latin donne pause
en français comme Rosa don rose et puis
c'est tout droit c'est très linéaire ça
a pas bougé depuis 25 ou 36 siècles bon
la pause pipi de notre enfant est devenu
une pause technique c'est quand même
assez amusant assez intéressant donc la
tech ben oui influencer nos vies nos
vies sont influencés par la technique on
dit aussi je fais une pause dans une
conversation un peu trop agitée comme
une pause sur notre ordinateur au milieu
d'une série voilà donc c'est amusant
cette ce rapport au corps qui est là et
puis il se trouve que cette semaine il
n'y a pas que Laurent Berger qui a
demandé une pause mais il y a aussi
précisément les géants de la tech c'est
la première fois que ça se passe très
important très important ce sont des
gens qui sont pris dans une course à
l'innovation et là ils demandent six
mois d'arrêt ne pose de break pour que
l'intelligence artificielle ne dépasse
pas ses créateurs en quelque sorte et
puis enfin j'ai entendu le mot à propos
de l'Ukraine parce qu'on est se mettre
dans un moment où on ne sait pas trop ce
qui va se passer et là le mot pause il a
une dimension évidemment qui nous ferait
envie de pacification on va pas jusque
là disons que c'est une suspension des
hostilités parce que les guerriers sont
fatigués en fait justement alors on voit
aussi qu'en France il y a pas mal de
fatigue dans l'air les côtés ministres
côté gouvernement côté député aussi oui
je pense que c'est pas autrement
étranger au fait que ce mot pose soit
arrivé parce qu'en fait il réfère
précisément à notre corps et il y a pas
de raison que les hommes politiques les
syndicalistes etc soit exemptées de
fatigue alors que tous les corps de
métiers le sont et le disent aujourd'hui
on le voit très bien et notre société
elle est très attentive au bien-être et
à la santé chez les jeunes on les voit
aussi ils sont très attentifs à cela ou
biorythme du corps chez les sportifs
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui pratiquement
tout le monde alors petit indice qui n'a
l'air de rien mais la pause déjeuner en
France elle est sacro-sainte on n'est
pas passé au lunchtime alors que
beaucoup de gens parlent anglais donc
tout ça pour dire qu'elle reste
fondamentale
elle est fondamentale alors pour sur ce
qui s'est passé avec le syndicalisme
évidemment Laurent Berger pouvait
appartient au syndicalisme dit
réformiste opposé à ceux qui seraient
aux forces qui seraient plus
révolutionnaires donc ça c'est un
dialectique qu'on connaît très très bien
ce que je me demande parce que je crois
que ce mot va avoir un grand avenir
c'est si on ne va pas passer de la même
façon entre une lutte entre les
jusqu'au-boutis il n'arrête jamais et
les posistes qui au contraire sont
capables de faire des pauses techniques
et politiques pour réfléchir peut-être
pour regarder un peu autrement la route
à faire merci passionnant voyage
sémantique sur le mot pause il y avait
plein de choses à dire en fait j'adore
merci Mariette vous aimez les pauses
c'est qu'aujourd'hui en politique
notamment chez les présidents enfin le
président la pause est vue comme un aveu
de faiblesse à chaque fois dans les
papiers ils aiment faire fuiter le côté
je ne dors pas beaucoup je n'arrête pas
alors que ça fait du bien absolument et
c'est le week end et on va en profiter
merci beaucoup les affranchis merci
Stéphanie et merci à vous à madichaouch
d'être passé sur le plateau de la Chaîne
Parlementaire dossier vétraide avec
Valentin psquée c'est aussi des éditions
pleines à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]